look it's my first time being tagged put
in somebody else's YouTube video so yeah
I'll do that
[Music]
so as the kind of lead-in implied a mr.
TARDIS reviews video he I don't know I
can't remember now if he mentioned he
was tagged by somebody else but he
talked about his and he gave a story
about his favorite piece of Doctor Who
memorabilia he then tagged through the
other YouTube channels to do the same
and a whole bunch of you folks alerted
me to this because I actually hadn't
checked my subscription feed in a little
bit so I hadn't seen it you you guys got
the word out real fast so now that's
that's what I'm gonna take a crack at
now I'm gonna put a link below it for
mr. TARDIS reviews in his video and if
you've already seen that one don't watch
it first because his is way better like
what he has and what he has to say about
it is way better because what I realized
when I do I stopped to to think about
you know the Doctor Who sort of bits
merch and you know memorabilia what have
you that I have the vast majority of it
is stuff that I have just bought for
myself
and nothing I was almost gonna say none
of it signed let me back up none of it
has been signed for me I have a couple
of sign things I have a print of David
Tennant first emerging out of the TARDIS
he's still wearing the leather jacket
that Eccleston had and that is signed
but that was bought that way you know
it's got a certificate of authenticity
or whatever but and and I like that very
much but I don't have the attachment
that one would have going to get
something of your sign to that same
width I showed these off to my patrons
some supporters but I'll tell you folks
about this one of my subscribers
actually sent to me some sign to
postcards of the seven
doctor and ace which are awesome and I
love them those those are now safely in
my my commission or portfolio so yeah
there's all that stuff and I love all
that stuff but none of it was signed for
me so I don't have a signed thing so I I
don't have the same level of
sentimentality involved now I'm actually
gonna kind of cheat and talk about two
things because I I couldn't decide
between those and I one is just
something I want to show off and then
the other I think has probably it
probably has the best story and I think
ultimately if I if I was told you can
only keep one piece of Doctor Who
memorabilia I it's what I would grab
okay so first up I mentioned it already
this this is my art portfolio when I go
to cons which is not something I was
able to do this year my favorite thing
to do is to get commissions I don't
stand in line forever to get things
signed I've only met you know a
celebrity appearance once that was Tim
Curry totally worth it but that's not
really my thing either I love the other
people I love the booths
you know the people and what they have
to sell and offer and I love going up
and down Artist Alley looking at the
style that various artists have and
thinking oh what character would I like
to see in that style and through that at
Vermont comic-con I acquired this that
my friends that is the silence in ink
wash and I feel like a jerk because the
the artists name is suddenly slipping my
mind but I am I am gonna link below to
his stuff because he does he does
awesome work that's said it's not I've
actually gotten commissions from him
twice he also did
Gozer for me and funny thing with the
silence he's not a Doctor Who fan so he
had to look up who these guys were but I
saw him on his phone look them up and I
could see like the wheels turn like oh
yeah I can work with that and so I loved
it
because this is probably the code that
I'm not the closest it is the most
personalized a piece of Doctor Who
related anything that I have but I think
ultimately at the end of the day I've
got to go with one of the sonic
screwdrivers and it is one specifically
now I've got the whole batch lined up
there and I want to talk specifically
now about this one this is rivers sonic
screwdriver which appeared in science
and library and forests of the Dead and
this was the very first sonic
screwdriver I ever got
now I mentioned most of the stuff that I
have was bought by my yeah I bought it
for me you know which makes it stuff
they like and it's cool but it removes a
lot of sentimental attachments I've
never bought a sonic screwdriver for
myself every single one you see up there
was a gift the majority of them nearly
all of them were Christmas gifts it's
actually become sort of the annual
stocking stuffer I get a new sonic
screwdriver and actually thank goodness
that there's there's a new sonic
screwdriver in time for Christmas this
year because otherwise I would have run
the risk of having to figure out
something else to you know Doctor Who
related to ask for it and it would have
felt a little weird but I love getting
these every year and they I I deeply
adore the person who give us them it's
it's my daughter's mother gives them to
me and still yes we're not together but
we still do Christmas together as a
family you know me and her and and our
daughter and she is still she's still
getting me bees and this was the first
one
she ever got me and she didn't pick this
cuz she watches Doctor Who because she
doesn't but I singled this out she she
had asked me you know if you could have
a sonic screwdriver what more would you
want and I said this one and the reason
being that at the time you know wanting
to start you're not knowing that it was
going to end up with with bruising a one
that was available one day I remember
thinking I want something that can feel
more like mine that could feel more like
an heirloom that could have been passed
to me and less like I took you know the
doctor screwdriver there's something
about rippers there's something about
the the wear on it the look on it the
haphazard nature you know bits come off
you've got the I gotta change the
battery and that you've got the got oh
no I don't it still works
huh a little ghosting signal that's all
that's all in there oh man that takes me
back
so the the thrown-together feel of it
makes it feel like something that
someone will put together and then pass
on not as like a precious heirloom but
as I you might need this one day yeah
and I always enjoyed that about this and
I always liked the design from from
seeing it for the very first time and I
love that this was the first sonic
screwdriver that I was ever given and
you know what we can also can switch it
back to blue cuz it's got a red setting
which is usually what I leave it on
because it makes it fairly unique among
the son of sure drivers except for the
war doctor that one's that one's red but
and there's I don't know if this will
pick up there is ever so slightly a
little bit of a different tone when it
switches to the red there
a trail to it so this this is the blue
we'll see if this even picks it up I
don't think you kind of hear it in the
background that's it's a bit of a
ringing kind of thing to it and I love
that there's a tiny bit of difference
and I don't know if that's purposeful or
not but it's just one more little touch
that makes it feel a little bit more
homegrown and as the kickoff to my
acquiring Doctor Who merchandise between
which one it is you know who gave it to
me and it being a start of so much stuff
yeah yeah I love this thing so like I
said I still I cannot top mister TARDIS
reviews story so if you didn't watch her
already you should not watch his video
because this is better and his the thing
that he has is better and his story is
amazing so check that out and yeah what
the heck I'll tag some people if they
haven't been tagged already they might
have been I'll go ahead and tag wingy
media and also Stu bagful if they feel
like it I I know it's the law of the
internet that you have to do it but you
know if you feel like you'd go for it
and to round that on a third it's not
gonna be youtuber it's gonna be a friend
of mine who blogs and podcasts so sis
coid over its this coins blog of geekery
if you feel like tossing this in on one
of your blog post updates or adding it
in as a tack on to a podcast you know
what I I would love to hear from you my
one my wonderful Canadian friend about
your favorite piece of Doctor Who merch
kit whatever you've got so yeah that's
it just spontaneously made cuz I got
tagged and other stuff there you go hope
you hope that you folks liked it and
that'll wrap it up for this one there's
a whole bunch of links down there
including to the
and the channels or the blogs of the
people quite tagged if you want to alert
them that I have done so maybe plus you
know a link to patreon and a whole bunch
of other stuff there's buttons and stuff
click some of them they go places so
remember folks you're the council I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]